so Ambassador thanks for talking to us
today yesterday a senior Ukrainian
security official said he expects his
government expects a major Russian
offensive within the coming months if
not the next two or three weeks what
kind of escalation can we expect you
think
well this isn't too hard to predict uh
if you look at just the conditions on
the ground and the weather I think many
people expect both the Russians and the
ukrainians to have some sort of spring
offensive we're at a moment right now
where both sides are still fighting but
I think the way we would describe it
right now is they're they're kind of
stuck in neutral there are little bits
of Victories each and every day coming
from either side but in terms of a big
emboldened move on the part of the
ukrainians or the Russians I think we
can anticipate that when the ground
isn't Frozen and where the weather
conditions get a bit better so as you
have heard in recent days and weeks what
the alliance is doing individual members
of The Alliance is ensuring that we get
as much equipment in the hands of the
Ukrainian military as possible so that
they could be ready for any coming
offensive so the Russians will go up a
year what kind of gear will they go up
to is it going to be a multi-front
attack do you think and how many troops
are there going throw into this Ward you
think it's hard to predict exactly what
the Russians have up their sleeve and
what they're planning if I were them I'd
certainly be looking at the whole array
of challenges that they've had over the
last year they know that they have major
challenges when it comes to command and
control but also Logistics and that's
been Apparent from day one since the war
started so obviously from a Russian
perspective they want to see if they can
hold the territory that they've been
able to seize the date but they also
have to face the reality that they
haven't been able to achieve their
strategic objectives on the ground can
we expect another attack on Cave do you
think from the Russians I don't think
anybody sees that coming at least for
now I mean they tried very hard to do
that at the beginning of the war and it
was apparent that there was no way that
they were going to be able to meet that
objective so we'll have to see again
it's hard to predict the war takes
different turns depending on the week
and month but right now I suspect that
they want to hang on to that territory
in the East and the South it's hard to
predict but presumably you're seeing
what ukrainians are seeing over the
Border how many troops are massing what
kind of arms and armor
and they're monitoring very closely
whether or not
or not inside Ukraine they're obviously
trying to predict whether or not the
Russians are going to go forward with an
additional round of mobilizations that
was a decision that they took last year
the question is do they need additional
forces on top of the mobilization that
they activated a couple of months back
so I will leave it to the ukrainians to
keep a close watchful eye on what's
happening in terms of how Russians are
preparing but again our focus is on
helping the ukrainians be at the ready
for any future contingency but to be in
that position I mean what I suppose what
I'm getting at is yes we can expect the
Russians to up the ante once the weather
improves but on what kind of scale do
you think they're going to launch this
new offensive at well it's hard to
predict the reality is that they have
real challenges they do not have the
forces that they need these guys that
are coming into the conflict we've seen
in recent months are not adequately
trained and the reality is that they're
facing their own munition shortages that
they are running out of PG GM so this is
not a situation where the Russians have
an endless supply of either equipment or
Manpower and so they're going to have to
be grappling with those challenges in
real time for any counter-offensive that
we're going to see them pursue this
spring so not not much of a threat then
if they've got all these reduced
capabilities we will see we will see
again it's hard to predict nobody has a
crystal ball but what we have seen is
the ukrainian's ability to pursue these
counter-offensive and have success on
the battlefield but the Russians are
mobilizing tens of thousands of soldiers
and as we've seen in solidar and back
they're prepared to send over wave after
wave of troops
how big a problem is that going to be
for the ukrainians well it's clear that
the Russians are trying to throw mass at
the problem but that doesn't make up for
Quality there's quantity in the quality
equation here and they can throw a lot
of Manpower at the problem but as we
just mentioned or as I just mentioned
it's tough given the lack of training
and the lack of capabilities that these
troops face but it could come in the
next few weeks would you agree with that
two or three weeks possibly well
honestly we don't know I think there is
an expectation that the spring will
bring a change and we'll have to see
what that actually transpires how that
transpires and will the hesitation over
sending tanks will that have cost
Ukraine in terms of its capability well
they have these tanks in time for that
Russian offensive I think the goal is
first and foremost to get the training
underway as soon as humanly possible and
that has started happening so first and
foremost we've got to train them up on
the tanks that are going to be coming in
and and then we need to rapidly move
those tanks and get them in the hands of
military commanders on the ground I
think everyone across the alliance
appreciates that time is of the essence
we appreciate the urgency of the
situation and the goal seems to be a
shared one not only across the Ramstein
Group which is the group of countries
that meets monthly to talk about
Ukraine's military requirements but also
across the NATO alliance the ukrainians
are saying it could come within the next
two or three weeks so these tanks are
not going to get there in time for that
are they I think it depends how fast we
can train them up on and how I mean the
one one thing that's been unbelievable
over the last year is the Ukrainian
militaries ability to train up on
equipment and utilize it in real time I
mean the way they have condensed the
period of training that is often
required for the systems that we have
given them has been nothing short of
remarkable so let's see how this
proceeds but again I think it's clear
that those countries donating the tanks
right now fully appreciate the urgency
military experts seem to think that
tanks modern battle tanks are no use
without air cover and modern fighter
jets why is your government not prepared
to send those well the president's
answer was no he was asked this question
directly right now the United States has
no decision to share as it relates to
aircraft or f-16s but I think
fundamentally as we've seen throughout
this war there are a couple of hard
questions you have to ask yourself
before you provide provide any
individual asset to Ukraine you have to
think about not only the training piece
but you also have to think about the
logistics tale you have to think about
maintenance and spare parts and so any
asset that's given to the ukrainians has
to have a series of questions answered
we also have to have a full
understanding of the Ukrainian Force's
ability to absorb those assets and use
them in real time and so you also heard
President Biden say that he's going to
have a conversation with President
zielinski we are in regular contact with
the ukrainians to talk about their
military requirements and will continue
to engage them in a conversation we
heard very similar things from officials
like yourself talking about tanks and
then finally America was giving tanks
and the argument is that the alliance is
giving Ukraine just enough to continue
this war but not to win it why not give
them everything they need to finish the
the war off I think what Western
countries and what other countries
around the world have given the
Ukrainian military forces has been
astounding when you think about where
this war started how we were all focused
on javelins and stingers and then moved
to munition shortages over the summer we
had a period where we were talking about
coastal defense and now we're very
focused not only on Armor but on
artillery we're looking at ammunition
and we continue to look at air defense I
think it is a full package of assets
that many countries have come together
to provide to the ukrainians and it has
had a real and lasting impact on the
battlefield the problem is once again
you're one stage behind what the
ukrainians say they need they say they
need fighter jets now and you're not
prepared to send them well as I said
with each asset you have to go through a
series of questions this isn't a case
where you can just snap your fingers and
suddenly send fighter jets if the
ukrainians don't have the pilots at the
ready if they haven't answered the
logistics question how to maintain these
types of assets so this has been an
evolution you're absolutely right we
have been in regular contact with the
ukrainians to hear from them in real
time what their requirements are
honestly those requirements have changed
they did not start out asking for f-16s
we are now at a point where we're
engaged in that type of conversation and
we'll see where that takes us but I I
don't think it's fair to say at any
given point the requirements have been
stagnant I mean their requirements have
changed based on what Russia is doing on
the ground and what their needs are on
the battlefield well they say their
requirements have changed or what they
what they need now is fighter jets and
that Poland and Holland are beginning to
think about sending them why isn't
America as well well we leave it in the
hands of every country to determine what
they want to give to Ukraine we're not
in a position to dictate that so we'll
let the polls in other countries
determine what they want to provide
Ukraine you heard our president I think
his answer was very clear I mean why if
I could put the criticism again the
criticism is that you're giving them
enough to continue the war not to win it
why not give them what they need right
now to finish the job off I think you're
underestimating the real victories that
they've had on the battlefield I mean
they were able to push the Russians away
from Kiev which was their original
objective and then when Russia went
forward and had its attempted and
illegal annexation of four different
corners of Ukraine the ukrainians then
went in and successfully were able to
retake that territory so they've had
remarkable success on the battlefield I
wouldn't want to undersell that and we
will do all we can to ensure that that
continues they have but the Russians are
now succeeding in places like solidar
and the ukrainians now so they expect a
major offensive that they won't be able
to repel unless they get more weapons
well we want to ensure that we can help
the Ukrainian with their own counter
offensive that will come later this year
and can the alliance keep up with the um
the pace of armament production
supplying enough shells in particular
and artillery pieces to the ukrainians
so there there's two problems two
challenges one we want to make sure that
the declining stocks that exist inside
Ukraine are adequately addressed by the
50 countries that are now providing
security assistance and we're working on
that through this Ramstein group that
meets on a monthly basis there's another
challenge and that is individual NATO
allies that are providing security
assistance are also now starting to
experience declining stocks and so as an
alliance we have to come together and
talk about how we can pursue
multinational buys pooled buys to
address some of those gaps that now
exist because of the assistance that's
flowing into Ukraine so NATO as an
alliance is taking this on for how it
relates to Nato members and then the ram
amstein group the 50 countries providing
assistance is looking at the shortfalls
on the Ukrainian side the Sydney
Ukrainian official yesterday said to us
that he expects the worst is yet to come
despite everything we've seen last year
do you expect worse to come this year
look I mean one thing that's been very
clear over this last year is that no one
has a crystal ball no one can predict
the way in which this is going to unfold
what we can predict is that Russians
will continue pushing they're trying to
defend the territory that they've taken
but I think it's safe to predict that
the ukrainians are going to do
everything they can to retake that
territory and again our goal is to
support them as they defend their
territory and their sovereignty against
this Russian aggression let me ask you
one about British defense funding
because earlier this week the defense
secretary Ben Warner said that Britain's
defense has been underfunded for decades
how big a worry is that is that for you
that a key member of the alliance its
military is being underfunded well I'll
tell you how we look at it we look at
the United Kingdom and we see that we
have no closer Ally bilateral Ally than
the United Kingdom why do we say that
because the United Kingdom is incredibly
capable it's a committed Ally we work
closely together not only in NATO but in
a lot of other multilateral institutions
and we work together bilaterally on a
whole array of challenges whether it's
defense issues Tech issues climate
change so we view the United Kingdom as
one of our closest bilateral partners
and that's the bottom line but is is it
a worry that its military isn't getting
the money that its own defense secretary
says it needs well you heard the UK's
defense secretary talk about the fact
that the United Kingdom is going to be
making additional investments in their
armed forces and I'll leave it to him to
comment on on the state of the British
Armed Forces but he seemed to
acknowledge that they would be making
additional Investments there and that's
something that we would applaud and
welcome is it a worry for you that with
the anniversary coming up and this seems
to be a worry for the ukrainians they
will use this the Russians as a date on
which they stage some kind of attempt at
a comeback
well what we want to do on the
anniversary is Herald the support and
unity that we've been able to maintain
for the last year President Putin was
sure that transatlantic Unity would
crumble he was sure that there would be
cracks as early as last fall as we moved
into the winter months I think the
prediction was that the alliance
couldn't hold but the reality is the
alliance is holding there's no crack in
Alliance Unity do we have debates and
differences inside the NATO alliance
absolutely each and every day we debate
a variety of issues tied to Ukraine but
despite those differences the fact that
we're still standing in support of
Ukraine after a year I think should come
as a surprise to President Putin and
should concern him because I don't see
any sign that individual member states
are heading for the exits well he had
major differences over tanks and that
was public and for everyone to see and
you may have them over fighter jets as
well and the the worry is I guess that
that is going to cost the ukrainians
lives and and may have already cost
lives over tanks in particular if this
offensive happens before the tanks can
get there in time we have differences
all the time across the NATO alliance we
have 75 years of experience in dealing
with our differences I'm confident that
whatever differences we'll continue to
have we will resolve we will work
through those differences the important
fact here is that Ukraine is going to be
getting those armored vehicles and the
tanks in the not too distant future and
that the alliance was able to Showcase
again Unity despite the differences
leading up to those decisions and one
last important question we've heard a
lot from the Russians in terms of
nuclear cyber rattling that the threat
of using tactical nuclear weapons has
that receded now do you think well we've
obviously looked at the nuclear saber
rattling with great concern you've heard
that our government has messaged Moscow
on this we've warned them about the
consequences of relying on their nuclear
Arsenal but I think what we have seen or
what we haven't seen is really any
indication in recent months that they're
preparing to use nuclear weapons so
we'll continue messaging them about the
dangers and the risks of doing that we
take it seriously but I think right now
we're reassured that we're not seeing an
indication that they're going to make a
move in that regard Ambassador thank you
very much thank you